j'ai ainsi vécu seul sans personne avec
qui parler véritablement j'ai donc
appris à piloter des avions
j'ai volé un peu partout dans le monde
jusqu'à une banane dans le désert du
sahara
s'il vous plaît
dessine moi un mouton
s'il vous plaît dessine moi un mouton
on
dessine moi un mouton quand le mystère
est trop impressionnant
on n'ose pas désobéir dessiner je sais
pas dessiner ça ne fait rien le premier
mouton que je dessinais était trop
malade et le deuxième non plus n'était
pas à son goût
tu vois bien c'est pas un mouton c'est
un bélier la décor est celui là était
trop vieux le mouton je veux il doit
vivre très longtemps
j'ai donc dessiné ceux ci
le mouton que tu veux et dedans tout à
fait comme ça que je voulais
quoi tu es faille beaucoup d art masse
moutons parce que chez moi c'est tout
petit je pense que ça suffira largement
je t'ai donné un tout petit mon temps
passé qui ça tiens regarde ils
s'étendent